I'm going to tell you about an
affliction I suffer from and I have a
funny feeling that quite a few of you
suffer from it as well when I'm walking
around an art gallery rooms and rooms
full of paintings after about 15 or 20
minutes I realize I'm not thinking about
the paintings I'm not connecting to them
instead I'm thinking about that cup of
coffee I desperately need to wake me up
I'm suffering from gallery fatigue how
many of you out there suffer from yes ha
ha ha ha sometimes you might last longer
than 20 minutes or even shorter but I
think we all suffer from it and do you
have the accompanying guilt for me I
look at the paintings on the wall and I
think somebody has decided to put them
there thinks they're good enough to be
on that wall but I don't always see it
in fact most of the time I don't see it
and I leave feeling actually unhappy I
feel guilty and and unhappy with myself
rather than thinking there's something
wrong with the painting I think there's
something wrong with me and that's not a
good experience to leave a gallery like
that the thing is I think we should give
ourselves a break if you think about
going into a restaurant when you look at
the menu are you expected to order every
single thing on the menu
no you select if you go into a
department store to buy a shirt are you
going to try on every single shirt and
want every single shirt of course not
you can be selective it's expected how
come then it's not so expected to be
selective when we go to an art gallery
why do are we supposed to have a
connection with every single painting
well I'm trying to take a different
approach and there's two things I do
when I go into a gallery first of all I
go quite fast and I look at everything
and I pinpoint the ones that make me
slow down for some reason or other I
don't even know why they make me slow
down but something pulls me like a
magnet and then I ignore all the others
and I just go to that painting so it's
the first thing I do is I
do my own curation I choose a painting
it might be c1 painting and 50 and then
the second thing I do is I stand in
front of that painting and I tell myself
a story about it
why story well I think that we are wired
our DNA tells us to tell stories we tell
stories all the time about everything
and I think we do it
because the world is kind of a crazy
chaotic place and sometimes stories
we're trying to make sense of the world
a little bit trying to bring some order
to it why not apply that to our looking
at paintings so I now have this sort of
restaurant menu visiting of art
galleries there are three paintings I'm
going to show you now that our paintings
that made me stop in my tracks and want
to tell stories about them the first one
needs little introduction girl with a
Pearl Earring by Johannes Vermeer 17th
century Dutch painter this is the most
glorious painting I first saw it when I
was 19 and I immediately went out and
got a poster of it and in fact I still
have that poster 30 years later is
hanging in my house it's accompanied me
everywhere I've gone I never tire of
looking at her what made me stop in my
tracks about her to begin with were just
the gorgeous colors he uses and the
light falling on her face but I think
what's kept me still coming back year
after year is another thing and that is
the look on her face the conflicted look
on her face I can't tell if she's happy
or sad and I changed my mind
all the time so that keeps me coming
back one day 16 years after I had this
poster on my wall I lay in bed and
looked at her and I suddenly thought I
wonder what the painter did to her to
make her look like that
and it was the first time I had ever
thought that the expression on her face
is actually reflecting how she feels
about him always before I thought of it
as a portrait of a girl now I began to
think of it as a portrait of a
relationship
and I thought well what is that
relationship so I went to find out I did
some research and discovered we have no
idea who she is in fact we don't know
who any of the models and any of
Vermeer's paintings are and we know very
little about Vermeer himself which made
me go
yippee I can do whatever I want I can
come up with whatever story I want to so
here's how I came up with this story
first of all I thought I've got to get
her into the house how does Vermeer know
her well there have been suggestions
that she is his 12 year old daughter the
daughter at the time was 12 when he
painted the painting and I thought no
it's a very intimate look but it's not a
look a daughter gives her father for one
thing in Dutch painting of the time if a
woman's mouth is open it was indicating
sexual availability it would have been
inappropriate for Vermeer to paint his
daughter like that so it's not his
daughter but it's somebody close to him
physically close to him well who else
would be in the house a servant a lovely
servant so she's in the house how do we
get her into the studio we don't know
very much about Vermeer but the little
bits that we do know one thing we know
is that he married a Catholic woman they
lived with her mother in a house where
he had his own room where he his studio
he also had eleven children it would
have been a chaotic noisy household and
if they've seen premieres paintings
before you know that they're incredibly
calm and quiet how does a painter paint
such calm quiet paintings with eleven
kids around well he compartmentalizes
his life he gets the studio and he says
nobody comes in here not the wife not
the kids
okay the maid can come in and clean
she's in the studio he's got her in the
studio they're together and he decides
to paint her he has her we're very plain
clothes now all of the women are mostly
women in Vermeer's other paintings wore
velvet silk for very sumptuous materials
this is very plain the only thing that
isn't plain is her pearl earring now
she's a servant there
is no way she could afford a pair of
pearl earrings so those are not her
pearl earrings whose are they we happen
to know there's a list of Caterina the
wife's clothes amongst them a yellow
coat with white fur a yellow and black
bodice and you see these clothes on lots
of other paintings different women in
the paintings of Vermeer's paintings so
clearly her clothes were lent to various
different women it's not such a leap of
faith to take that that pearl earring
actually belongs to his wife so we've
got all the elements for our story she's
in the studio with him for a long time
these paintings took a long time to make
they would have spent them time alone
all that time she's wearing his wife's
pearl earring she's gorgeous she
obviously loves him she's conflicted and
does the wife know maybe not and if she
doesn't well that's the story the next
painting I'm going to talk about is
called boy building a house of cards by
Xiao dong
he's an 18th century French painter best
known for his still lifes but he did
occasionally paint people and in fact he
painted four versions of this painting
different boys building houses of cards
all concentrated I like this version the
best because some of the boys are older
and some are younger and to me this one
like oldie Laxus porridge is just right
he's not quite a child and he's not
quite a man he's absolutely balanced
between innocence and experience and
that made me stop in my tracks in front
of this painting and I looked at his
face it's like a Vermeer painting a bit
the light comes in from the left his
face is bathed in this glowing light is
right in the center of the painting you
look at it and I found that when I was
looking at it my standing there going
look at me please look at me he didn't
look at me he was still looking at his
cards and that's one of the seductive
elements of this painting is he's so
focused on what he's doing that he
doesn't look at us
and that is to me the sign of a
masterpiece of painting when there's not
lack of resolution he's never going to
look at me
so I was thinking of a story where I
find in this position who could be there
looking at him not the painter I don't
want to think about the painter I'm
thinking of some an older version of
himself he's a man a servant an older
servant looking at this younger servant
saying look at me I want to warn you
about what you're about to go through
please look at me and he never does and
that lack of resolution the lack of
resolution and girl with a Pearl Earring
we don't know if she's happy or sad I've
written an entire novel about her and I
still don't know if she's happy or sad
again and again back to the painting
looking for the answer looking for the
story to fill in that gap and we may
make a story and it satisfies us
momentarily but not out not really and
we come back again and again the last
painting I'm going to talk about is
called anonymous by anonymous this is a
Tudor portrait bought by the National
Portrait Gallery they thought it was a
man named Sir Thomas over Bray and then
they discovered that it wasn't him and
they have no idea who it is now in the
National Portrait Gallery if you don't
know the biography of the painting it's
kind of useless to you they can't hang
it on the wall because they don't know
who he is
so unfortunately this orphan spends most
of his time in storage along with quite
a number of other orphans
some of them some beautiful paintings
this painting made me stop in my tracks
for three reasons one is the
disconnection between his mouth
smiling and his eyes that are wistful
he's not happy and why isn't he happy
the second thing that really attracted
me were his bright red cheeks he is
blushing
he's blushing for his portrait being
made this must be a guy who blushes all
the time what is he thinking about
that's making him blush the third thing
that made me stop in my tracks is his
absolutely gorgeous doublet silk grey
those beautiful buttons and you know
what it makes me think of is it's sort
of snow
and puffy it's like a duvet spread over
a bed I kept thinking of beds and red
cheeks and of course I kept thinking of
sex when I looked at him and I thought
is how what he's thinking about and I
thought if I'm going to make a story
what's the last thing I'm going to put
in there well what would a Tudor
gentleman be preoccupied with and I
thought well Henry the eighth okay he'd
be preoccupied with his inheritance with
his heir who is going to inherit his
name and his fortune you put all those
together and you've got your story to
fill in that gap that makes you keep
coming back now here's the story it's
short rosy I am still wearing the white
brocade doublet Caroline gave me it has
a plain high collar detachable sleeves
and intricate buttons of twisted silk
thread set close together so that the
fit is snug the doublet makes me think
of a coverlet on the vast bed perhaps
that was the intention I first wore it
at an elaborate dinner her parents held
in our honor I knew even before I stood
up to speak that my cheeks were inflamed
I have always flushed easily from
physical exertion from wine from high
emotion as a boy I was teased by my
sisters and by schoolboys but not by
George only George could call me Rosie I
would not allow anyone else he managed
to make the word tender when I made the
announcement George did not turn rosy
but went pale as my doublet he should
not have been surprised it has been a
common assumption that I would one day
marry his cousin but it is difficult to
hear the words aloud I know I could
barely utter them afterwards I found
George on the terrace overlooking the
kitchen garden despite drinking steadily
all afternoon he was still pale we stood
together and watched the maids cut
lettuces what
do you think of my doublet I asked he
glanced at me that collar looks to be
strangling you we will still see each
other I insisted we can still hunt and
play cards and attend court nothing need
change George did not speak I am 23
years old it is time for me to marry and
produce an heir it is expected of me
George drained another glass of claret
and turned to me congratulations on your
upcoming nuptials James I'm sure you'll
be content together he never used my
nickname again thank you